une grenade vient d'exploser à côté de
cette brasserie la cible inde rockstore
très fréquentée du boulevard saint
germain
bilan deux morts et 34 blessés un
attentat revendiqué par carlos dans un
entretien publié en 1979
et depuis c'est le seul élément retenu à
sa charge dans ce dossier instruit par
le juge antiterroriste jean louis
bruguière 24 ans après les faits la cour
d'appel de paris vient de clore cette
affaire par manque de preuves
donnant droit à la requête déposée par
ses défenseurs
le principe c'est la présomption
d'innocence je ne vois pas pourquoi
carlos comme roland dumas ou qui que ce
soit n'auraient pas droit à la
présomption d'innocence
je dis donc les juges en ont eu assez
juge à la chambre d'accusation n'ont eu
assez de servir d'alibi à des intérêts
politiques qui ne sont pas ceux de la
justice à savoir la recherche de la
vérité et ils ont d'autres tranché pour
l'association sos attentats selon lui
est aussi inattendue que choquant elle
entend d'ailleurs se pouvoir en
cassation dès lundi pour vice de
procédure
forcément que c'est
en mémoire des victimes de 1974 au
drugstore il est tout à fait des
missiles tous puissent échapper à la
justice pour un crime qu'il a revendiqué
ce non lieu ne bouleversera pas le sort
de carlos en 97 il est condamné à
perpétuité pour l'assassinât de deux
policiers un crime commis rue toullier à
paris le 27 juin 75
bref carlos ne quittera pas la prison de
la santé où il séjourne depuis 94
sans compter les autres procédures
toujours en cours contre l'ancien chef
terroriste